[Música]
después de cuatro días de búsqueda la
guardia costera de Estados Unidos estimó
que el submarino titán que pretendía
explorar los restos del Titanic habría
implosionado y la compañía que programó
el viaje Ocean Gates expeditions apunta
a que los cinco viajeros estarían
muertos incluido Stockton Brush el
fundador y director ejecutivo de la
empresa las autoridades encontraron
escombros en el área de rastreo en el
fondo del Océano Atlántico Norte y creen
que serían los restos del sumergible de
igual manera las provisiones de oxígeno
dentro de la nave se calculaban para 96
horas un tiempo que se agotó en la
mañana del jueves justo antes de los
hallazgos por eso la guardia es
escéptica Incluso en que puedan
encontrar los cadáveres estos fueron
algunos de los detalles que revelaron
esta mañana un vehículo operado por
control remoto del buque horizonartic
descubrió el cono de la cola del
sumergible titán Aproximadamente a 1600
pies de la prueba del Titanic en el
fondo del mar
Posteriormente se encontraron escombros
adicionales
en consulta con expertos del Comando
unificado los escombros son consistentes
con la pérdida catastrófica de la cámara
de presión
así los cinco tripulantes que pagaron
50.000 dólares por el viaje terminaron
en el peor de los escenarios lo que abre
la pregunta de cuánto están dispuestos a
pagar los multimillonarios por un
turismo extremo que es nuestro tema del
día sin embargo no podemos comenzar este
debate sin hacer hincapié en el amplio
despliegue mediático y de recursos en la
búsqueda que ha tenido esta operación en
contraste con la tragedia de los más de
500 migrantes en las costas de Grecia
que intentaba llegar de Libia a Italia y
donde aún cientos de personas siguen
desaparecidas luego del naufragio de su
embarcación porque llama más la atención
una tragedia que la otra para discutir
este y más temas como los riesgos de
cierto tipo de turismo y sus alcances
hoy en el debate nos acompañan nuestro
estudio Oscar Iván Ojeda magister en
ingeniería aeroespacial y director de la
fundación sidonia en Ciudad de México
está allá en puth Franco presidente de
expertos en turismo y desde chile se
conecta Rubén escribano director del
instituto Milenio de oceanografía a
ellos les doy la bienvenida de a ustedes
nuestra audiencia Los invito a que dejen
sus comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales con el numeral el debate f-24
estamos en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
como arroba franz24-raya el piso e s y a
mí me encuentran en Twitter como arroba
María claguire además quiero saludar a
quienes escuchan este debate en podcast
a través de las plataformas de Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
para comenzar le doy la bienvenida a
Rubén escribano Rubén Gracias por
acompañarnos y empecemos por la pregunta
que nos hace tener este debate Y es que
está ocurriendo por lo menos de lo que
se sabe que ha pasado con el sumergible
titán
Hola buenas Buenas tardes desde chile
desde Concepción Muchas gracias por la
invitación encantado de colaborar
Sí bueno era lo que teníamos no que Este
esta nave este submarino no
Aparentemente no resistió la presión
Aquí estaba sometido acerca de cuatro
mil cuatro mil metros de profundidad
digamos que la estructura
estaba en en su en sus límites de diseño
para resistir una tremenda presión que
ejerce el agua la columna de agua sobre
cualquier de cualquier artefacto que
esté en esa condición en ese ambiente
Así que Aparentemente ocurrió un evento
catastrófico quizás una falla de
material una fisura en el casco que
gatillo digamos a esta Aparentemente
está implosión No es cierto es la plata
al viento con la presión de esta nave
usted habla de los límites en el diseño
y los llama así específicamente Y es que
ha habido dos discusiones que quiero que
usted nos ponga en contexto por un lado
se ha criticado que este sumergible
titán se manejara sobre todo con un
control de videojuegos y por el otro
lado las características que tenía Pues
estaba fabricado con fibra de carbono y
titanio qué tan resistente es esto sobre
todo cuando estamos a más de 3000 metros
en la profundidad con toda la presión
que hace el agua
Bueno es un ambiente extremo en la
presión realmente es tremendamente y una
fuerza muy muy grande sin embargo sin
embargo esto esto aparato está
construido con suficiente tecnología
para resistir la alta presión
yo conozco estos aparatos yo estuve en
una inmersión similar a 7.500 metros de
profundidad con un equipo similar y sé
que hay bastante seguridad en estas
naves sin embargo un evento catastrófico
ocurre posiblemente porque hubo alguna
falla en algún material en alguna fisura
algo que es un es un accidente No no es
que no es que el equipo esté Siempre en
alto riesgo en este caso creo que fue un
accidente una falla que no estaba
digamos en los cálculos de la ingeniería
del equipo
quiero ahora regresar a nuestro estudio
para darle la bienvenida a Oscar Iván
Ojeda Oscar Gracias por estar con
nosotros se dice que se conoce o que la
humanidad conoce más lo que hay en el
espacio que lo que hay en el océano
usted coincide con esto se ha dicho
mucho no que se conoce más de la
superficie de la luna y martes se llama
piado mejor que el fondo marino y
precisamente es por la gran dificultad
que hay en ir al fondo marino no es
decir estas grandes profundidades
precisamente por la cantidad de agua
Pues suena un poco tonto decirlo la
cantidad de agua que tenemos ahí no
permite explorarlas de manera apropiada
sin embargo pues la superficie es
planetarias están
dispuestas digamos despejadas para poder
ser exploradas Entonces sí es una
afirmación que de una u otra forma es
cierta y pues hay que decir la
superficie de la luna y Marte es más
pequeña en términos de área que lo que
es la superficie
el suelo oceánico usted habla entonces
de dos razones por las que se podría
conocer más el espacio que el océano y
sin embargo
hay más hasta ahora viajes turísticos al
fondo del mar que al espacio de hecho
hay dos grandes compañías space x del
multimillonario elon musk y por el otro
lado Virgin galactic de Richard branson
y sin embargo todavía no ha despegado el
primer vuelo comercial al espacio y por
ejemplo Ocean Expedition que es la
compañía que estaba haciendo este
sumergible así a viajes para ver el
Titanic desde el 2021 A qué se debe esto
Bueno hay tres compañías la otra es Blue
origin de Jeff que Pues digamos que
todos son multimillonarios y ha habido
algunos viajes
y ya comerciales espaciales en
particular por este nuevo paradigma de
lo que es el newspace que llaman algunas
personas en tenemos la exploración
espacial como un servicio
se incorpora dentro de una lógica de
Mercado en la cual ya organizaciones
como la NASA no son las que operan todos
los vehículos a pesar de que digamos que
siempre han sido construidos por
terceros no solo Lo operan sino que ya
compran el servicio es decir es como
básicamente pedir un taxi de hecho
varios ha habido varios chistes Dentro
de este proceso de de lanzamiento los
cuales dicen como Gracias por volar con
spacex y ese tipo de cosas en los cuales
es un servicio comercial y ha habido
algunos intentos de Pues de promover
estos viajes más al nivel suborbital que
es básicamente dar un pequeño saltito en
la atmósfera superar esa línea de lo que
está denominado como el espacio según
algunas definiciones y hay otro tipo de
viajes como empresas como action space
que utilizando las cápsulas de spacex lo
que hacen es que brindan servicios para
que personas particulares con fines
privados vayan al espacio visiten la
estación espacial internacional y otros
vuelos más más cortos pero ya a nivel
orbital quiero darle la bienvenida ahora
a Ian put Ian Cómo entender este repunte
del deseo de turistas de viajar o a las
profundidades del mar o soñar con viajar
a lugares tan remotos como la luna
Claro que sí yo creo que una de las
situaciones del ser humano del viaje
siempre es poder llegar más lejos
entonces el ser humano lo va a hacer en
todas sus características tanto tratando
de llegar al espacio como tratando de
llegar a los puntos más altos como el
Everest tratado de llegar a los puntos
subacuáticos más profundos y
representativos como la amistad Titanic
y podemos llegar lo más lejos como los
viajes en velero que se hacen desde hace
años de manera turística para poder
hacer este tipo de cosas y y los viajes
en globo y Cuánta actividad humana de
este tipo representa un riesgo no
acabamos de ver en México en Teotihuacán
se se prendió un globo aerostático ha
habido accidentes de parapente habíamos
hemos visto repetidas ocasiones personas
que se han quedado varadas No nada más
en el Everest hay una placa muy
representativa en un volcán aquí al lado
del volcán que está al lado del
Popocatépetl que por todo está activo
que es el Iztaccíhuatl de una persona
que dice escaló el Everest escaló el k2
el kilimanjaro falleció en el
Popocatépetl En el Iztaccíhuatl Entonces
yo cuando vi eso y estaba escalando eso
me daba miedo porque decía Oye hiciste
cuatro experimentado lo vi falleció en
una montaña que ya salta montaña que es
relativamente más sencilla Entonces el
riesgo de fallecer tratando de llegar a
estos lugares más lejanos siempre es una
posibilidad todo o sea ya ni hablar de
ocero profundo su espacio siempre es una
cosa que puede ocurrir y puede sucederte
desde un globo aerostático hasta un
vuelo parapente o un viaje neutral
ligero y si hubiera hay diferentes
variedades tanto de turismo como de
experiencias usted menciona dos que
tienen una gran diferencia la primera de
ellas es una cosa es montar en globo
para lo que uno no necesita experticia
pero otra es escalar altos Montes como
las que usted mencionó o viajar a ver
los restos del Titanic al respecto hay
un debate de esta clase de turismo y la
empresa Ocean Gate dice que ellos no
eran turistas porque siempre hacen un
entrenamiento y dicen que es bastante
coordinado para que puedan descender al
fondo del mar Le quiero preguntar Rubén
qué tanto entrenamiento se necesita en
esta clase de misiones como la que
visitó el Titanic
Sí mira no no hay una preparación física
especial Porque cuando uno se sumerge en
un en un mini submarino uno lleva el
ambiente el ambiente que tiene a la
superficie Entonces no se requiere una
preparación física especial pero sí una
preparación psicológica que es muy
importante porque uno va a estar
sometido un estrés intenso
además
si uno sufre de claustrofobia eso es
imposible hacer este esta Misión y más
bien la preparación es psicológica el la
inducción misma la preparación para
sumergirse mismo es muy breve es son
algunas instrucciones sencillas sobre
cómo ingresar al aparato
Cómo mantenerse adentro Qué cosa Hay que
hacer Qué cosa no se pueden hacer es una
instrucción pequeña pero físicamente no
requiere una preparación psicológica sí
y para entender precisamente más de la
preparación psicológica que se necesita
hablemos desde su experiencia personal
usted ahora mencionó que descendió 7.500
metros esto en la fosa del atacama Y es
más o menos el doble de la profundidad
que alcanzó el sumergible titán Cómo es
el océano en ese punto y que además no
llega la luz porque la luz solar llega
hasta el metro mil
sí Bueno en realidad en la zona costera
la luz a los 50 metros ya se apaga ya no
hay luz
es un ambiente muy frío
oscuro absolutamente
además muy silencioso hay mucha vida en
el fondo Marino hay mucha vida uno puede
ver mucha actividad biológica y
y bueno la preparación psicológica
significa esencialmente poner la mente
fría una vez que uno toma la decisión de
sumergirse asumir todo lo que significa
y mantener la calma mantener la cabeza
muy fría muy calma desde el principio
hasta el final eso es esencialmente
y ahora le quiero preguntar a usted a
Óscar porque en la fundación ustedes
tienen un estudio para simular
distintos escenarios planetarios para
poder recrear y prepararse para los
viajes espaciales usted coincide con
Rubén llevándolo al tema de los vuelos
espaciales que se necesita más que todo
una preparación mental Claro que aquí
también la física es fundamental Sí en
el vuelo espacial lo que pasa es que las
personas están sometidas a aceleraciones
a unas condiciones que van a cambiar y
por ejemplo los procesos de selecciones
de astronautas profesionales de las
agencias espaciales y son muy rigurosos
porque son personas que van a estar en
lugares remotos autónomos durante un
largo tiempo y no queremos que estas
personas tengan problemas de salud
mientras están a bordo Entonces se hacen
esos procesos de selección personas que
prácticamente tienen salud perfecta sin
embargo Pues bueno
los vuelos un poco más comerciales que
se han realizado no se necesita una una
preparación mucho más allá aparte de una
revisión mucho más allá de lo que se
necesitaría para un vuelo comercial en
términos de que estas personas el tiempo
que están en el espacio son minutos es
un tiempo corto Y básicamente Es como
estar en un avión comercial en términos
de de la experiencia de estar sentado
obviamente hay ingravidez eso hace tiene
algunos cambios Pero no alcanzan a hacer
tanto tiempo como para que sean cambios
y que pongan en riesgo significativo la
salud de una persona que tenga una salud
normal de hecho hay personas de edad
avanzada que han tenido la oportunidad
de volar con Blue origin y ya en la
parte psicológica en los vuelos
prolongados en las personas que han ido
como turistas a la estación espacial
internacional
en ocasiones anteriores multimillonarios
que pagan decenas de millones de dólares
por estar unos días en la estación
espacial ya hay un entrenamiento también
la parte operativa de cómo voy a
comportarme yo que puedo hacer que puedo
no hacer Qué tipo de cosas se esperan de
mí como tripulante como actuar en caso
de una emergencia y precisamente en aquí
en la estación que tenemos para simular
este tipo de cosas en en Colombia La
idea es que queremos explorar es esa
parte mental del confinamiento en
misiones de larga duración te quiero
preguntar usted menciona que sí se
necesita cierta preparación Aunque es
diferente y que varía dependiendo de si
el viaje va a ser de larga duración y
menciona que ha habido turistas o
personas civiles por decirlo así que han
viajado a las a las estaciones espacial
internacional desde cuándo se conoce
esta versión comercial de los vuelos
aéreos espaciales
es en realidad ya un tema de largo
aliento de hecho desde la el principio
de los ha habido este interés de
personas que bueno Yo quiero participar
de este duelo en este momento también
hay cápsulas rusas las soyuz que
permiten llevar personas a la estación
espacial internacional en conjunto con
las cápsulas Dragon de spacex y
de una u otra forma como justificaban
también un poco el tema de estas
expediciones
submarinas hay un tema de financiación
sí es decir estos programas Por lo
general no cuentan con una financiación
grande y estas personas aparecen como
Bueno yo quiero comprar una silla en
esta cápsula Entonces eso permite
financiar parte del programa espacial y
esto lo que hace pues es facilitar que
haya personas que pues pasan por todo el
entrenamiento hacen todo este proceso
vuelan y pues se generan algunos
ingresos a través de esto el interés ha
estado Pero ha estado restringido y de
una u otra forma lo que buscan es
democratizar este acceso al al espacio
con estos nuevos vuelos que aún así pues
250 mil dólares es complejo pero pues
es ya no son millones de dólares sí pero
yo creo que ahí la palabra democratizar
dentro del debate te quiero
hayan si Dentro de este turismo en el
océano o en el espacio Hay algún plan
actualmente que contemple la
capacitación de las personas que van a
hacer estos viajes una capacitación
tanto física como mental
yo creo que está muy bien el tema de
este tipo de capacitaciones en estos
rubros específicos la realidad es que
debe haber una capacitación
comentabas es que ellos alegaban que no
era turismo porque yo hago una
capacitación o porque se tenía que
preparar la gente para poder hacer esta
prueba pero eso se hace prácticamente
también cualquier otro producto
turístico O sea si tú vas a bucear en
Tulum Pues tienes que tener la
certificación si tú vas a hacer cierto
tipo de montaña pues debes de haber
hecho botellas antes si tú vas a ser
cierto tipo de turismo A lo mejor de
determinado tipo de aventura de ciclismo
es necesario tener cierto tipo de
entrenamiento entonces cada tipo de
turismo sobre todo ese tipo de turismo
extremo Si requiere una capacitación lo
que pasa es que al ser un dicho como
dice el compañero muy pequeño que está
poco democratizado es cierto que a veces
no existe una instancia legal que te
diga Cuál es el los rulos que van a
hacer sobre todo en este caso que tengo
entendido que estando incluso creo que
en aguas internacionales
difícil a creer A qué país por ejemplo
en mi país existe la secretaría de
turismo en México este a través de
cierto tipo de
capacitaciones para guías de turistas de
turismo de Aventura pero ya hablar de un
turismo espacial en donde es ya difícil
saber que
legislación le aplica a cada país o en
aguas internacionales esto se complica
bastante no Entonces es muy difícil
decir cuáles serán los puntos ABC que
tendrían que tener mínimos para poder
realizar este tipo de de Aventura o de
este tipo de realización de actividad
turística y usted cree que sea probable
o por lo menos alcanzable cierta
regulación en esta clase de turismo uno
para evitar este sobrecosto y dos para
limitar Hasta cierto punto también los
riesgos que enfrentan
Yo creo que es muy complicado eh Porque
Incluso en Industrias más avanzadas lo
vimos Por ejemplo ahorita el tema de por
ejemplo la Aviación es bastante
complicada porque cuando hablamos de
Aviación volvemos al ejemplo de los
Globos aerostáticos es que no tendrá La
regulación o sí o no Eh Pues sí una cosa
es operaron un Ultra ligero otra cosa es
un globo aerostático otra cosa es a la
Delta otra cosa es incluso entonces a
veces es tan complicado porque sería
regular todos los tipos de turismo y los
que se nos vayan a ocurrir nuevos no
como decían desde hace muy poco tiempo
se llevaba a cabo este turismo de
inversión
en aguas profundas de manera comercial y
cuáles van a seguir existiendo van a ser
todavía más no o sea los que existan
dependiendo la tecnología no Entonces
tendremos que regular el turismo por
ejemplo de otra de pilotaje de drones
que ya está sucediendo Dubai Tendremos
que y Habría que ver una legislación y
dependerá mucho del país recordemos que
no hay legislaciones de este tipo
putiales no O sea hay algunas regionales
como europeas pero en este caso cada
país dependerá y y se va dando lo
lamentable lo lamentable de esto es que
no existe legislación o no se hace
legislación de este tipo hasta que pasa
algo probablemente ahora que sí hubo un
accidente probablemente se regule pero
siempre pasa después de no O sea la
regulaciones por ejemplo globos
artísticos está viendo ahorita después
del accidente ahorita que hubo
Teotihuacán o cuando pasa algún tipo de
accidente entonces
Lamentablemente cuando pasa algo cuando
algo es muy nuevo
no no se regula hasta que hay un
accidente no
Le quiero preguntar de este tema a Rubén
precisamente sobre si hay cierto tipo de
regulación en el turismo en las
profundidades del océano y también
Cuáles son las limitantes tecnológicas y
científicas es decir qué clase de
sumergibles se necesitan para este
turismo A diferencia de los que se
necesitan para hacer una expedición
científica o demás
sí Bueno mira regulación pienso que esto
es muy nuevo esto no no hay regulaciones
específicamente para el turismo en este
tipo de aventuras y tal vez tiene mucho
que ver con la jurisdicción en en el uso
y la operaciones que ocurren en el
océano Y eso depende de cada país en
muchos países normalmente Esto está
controlado por la la Marina la la la la
Armada o la Navy y
en ese caso son ellos quienes tienen la
jurisdicción o la prisión sobre
controlar de alguna manera la operación
Pero no específicamente dirigida al
turismo ahora
es la característica para este tipo de
inmersiones en aguas muy profunda
estamos hablando una tecnología de alto
costo
de mucho costo Porque se requiere
materiales muy especiales como el
titanio que tiene un costo y el diseño
mismo también es requiere mucha
ingeniería mucha tecnología entonces
imposible pensar que por ahora digamos
esta tecnología está el alcance de de
cualquier persona por eso el costo es
demasiado alto para cualquier persona
que quiera hacer turismo de este nivel a
esta a esta profundidad el digamos los
submarinos convencionales normalmente
pueden llegar a los quinientos
seiscientos metros ese es un submarino
convencional un submarino de guerra pero
aquí estamos hablando de
profundidades mayores a mil metros o sea
cien veces la presión que se ejerce la
superficie del mar Entonces
esto realmente es de alto costo y de una
tecnología muy muy sofisticada que no
está al alcance de cualquier país
siquiera nosotros en Chile por ejemplo
no tenemos
recursos ni tecnología para poder
diseñar aparatos de este nivel y si es
que podemos hacer investigación
científica en agua muy profunda
necesitamos la colaboración
internacional necesitamos el apoyo de
países desarrollados que puedan proveer
los recursos y la tecnología para este
tipo de operaciones en nuestros países
aún no existen digamos el desarrollo
suficiente para para poder diseñar esto
estas naves un alto precio y una
tecnología bastante avanzada que muchos
países como chile no tienen son algunas
de las dos características necesarias
para estos viajes turísticos en el fondo
del mar teniendo en cuenta estas
dificultades para ustedes polémico que
haya turismo comercial como el de titán
para viajar al Titanic sobre todo
sabiendo que se utilizan esos recursos
para que cinco personas vea Cómo quedó
el Titanic
sí En mi opinión esto nosotros nosotros
por lo menos lo lo vemos del punto de
vista científico
asumimos riesgo pero siempre con una un
margen de seguridad bastante alto por
ejemplo
en la nave que yo pude descender el
diseño estaba preparado para resistir
hasta 14.000 metros de profundidad
Entonces teníamos un margen de de
seguridad bastante amplio para resistir
la presión llegando hasta nosotros
pudimos llegar hasta ocho mil metros y
con un margen bastante amplio de
seguridad entonces
en el ámbito científico
la seguridad de las personas es
fundamental O sea no se no se realiza
ninguna misión si no hay 100% de
seguridad y un margen de seguridad
amplio y además sistemas redundantes que
hablamos nosotros sistemas que permiten
resolver cualquier emergencia a través
de varios mecanismos entonces
en el área turística yo desconozco
Realmente si es que existen esos niveles
de seguridad esos márgenes de seguridad
que al menos nosotros utilizamos en en
la exploración científica Oscar le
devuelvo a usted la pregunta usted
considera polémico o absolutamente
normal que haya viajes comerciales y que
se dedique tantos recursos y tanta
tecnología y tanta ciencia para que
privados viajen al espacio
Pues hay una una primera acotación
digamos con respecto a lo que veníamos
diciendo y es que tristemente las
regulaciones se escriben con sangre no
es es un dicho que que hay y es cierto
por ejemplo la Aviación comercial
básicamente en este momento estamos en
un punto en el que uno puede entrar una
página web encontrar un tiquete a
cualquier lugar del mundo pues
obviamente si uno tiene el dinero y casi
con certeza uno sabe que uno va a llegar
al otro lado del mundo
es difícil que lleguemos a un punto así
y no es por ser pesimista yo como Pues
digamos apasionado el tema espacial
Además de que es mi mi campo Me
encantaría Ver ver una gran cantidad de
desarrollos aeroespaciales pero hay que
entender que acá estamos hablando de de
un evento un lanzamiento de un cohete
por la misma naturaleza es supremamente
energético es uno órdenes de magnitud
más grande que lo que se hace
normalmente digamos en un proceso de de
Aviación
y y llegar a controlar eso de una manera
apropiada va a tomar mucho tiempo
posiblemente en el futuro no quiero ser
digamos pesimista de que de que no lo
veamos Y en este momento un poco lo que
mencionaba acerca de la de la
financiación es decir podemos decir que
parte de esto se financie con recursos
que que vengan de estas expediciones
puede ser una respuesta pero lo más
importante es que la gente tenga
Claridad de los riesgos de pronto en los
lanzamientos de cohetes pueden ser un
poco más regulados por por la el entorno
en el que se desarrollan por los
permisos que se tienen que solicitar
para poder lanzarlos porque hay unas
aprobaciones
pero es importante que la gente entienda
que sea lo que sea Estos son vehículos
experimentales que hay riesgos y que
esto no es rutinario entonces más que
controversial yo diría que es es
importante que esta industria le muestre
a la gente que es lo que está pasando no
de pronto como lo hizo esta empresa
decir parte del riesgo es que te puedes
morir que pues parte de lo divertido
Perdón es que te puedes morir que sí la
verdad no no es atractivo en el sentido
de que es importante que la gente tenga
riesgos controlados Sí hay astronautas
de carrera que van a devolver a la luna
que con todos los riesgos que esto
conlleva pero precisamente por eso es
que el viaje espacial tripulado es tan
tan demorado sí porque tenemos que
seguir unos pasos para poder llegar allá
sin embargo si hay una clase de viaje
que puede ser más fácil de hacer y una
clase de turismo que puede sonar más
cotidiano pero que aún implica
demasiados riesgos recientemente se
conoció que la compañía alemana Wander
mood está ofreciendo viajes de trekking
es decir
caminatas por la selva y las está
ofreciendo sobre todo para turistas
europeos y que atraviesen uno de los
puntos migratorios más mortíferos del
planeta que es el tapón del Darién que
comunica a Colombia con Panamá y que en
este momento es una de las rutas más
utilizadas en América para llegar a
Estados Unidos y sin embargo esta
empresa alemana lo está convirtiendo en
un viaje turístico Usted qué opina al
respecto
Pues yo creo que todo ese tema de los
riesgos es también forma parte de un
turismo negro que la gente siempre va a
buscar hacer como dice por ahí si no
genera riesgo si no genera adrenalina
sería es algo que la gente luego no le O
sea hay un público para ese tipo de
cosas en México hay una cosa que se
llama experiencia migrante que si no se
hace en la frontera de México Estados
Unidos pero se hace una cosa parecida en
la cual tú pagas para para hacer un
migrante por una noche lo hace vivir en
Hidalgo y simulan ser policías simula
ser la migración simula hacer los mismos
darcos y los coyotes que son los que los
agarran y los medios jalonean y eso
obedece también a un tema de de riesgo
quería retomar tantito el tema de lo que
decías que si vale la pena invertir
tantos recursos es una cosa que ya había
yo
rebancado en un en un texto que hice en
una revista nada más pongo como un tema
importante el primer viaje
internacional que se dio fue
hace más de Cien años este en un avión
en un aeródromo que despegó de una
ciudad cerca de Londres a un poblado
cerca de París solamente había un
pasajero y ese fue el primer vuelo
Internacional del mundo
obviamente un millonario que te da mucho
dinero que quería hacer este viaje ya lo
que voy con todo esto es
así empiezan los los viajes comerciales
o sea hace Cien años una sola persona
podía volar de un país a otro y ahora
los vuelos comerciales tienen millones
de personas hoy solamente un grupo
pequeño puede volar al espacio Pero
dentro de Cien años van a ser muchas
personas las que lo van a poder hacer
hoy a lo mejor hay tres cuatro personas
que viajan a hocico a la profundidades
del agua Pero el día de mañana cuando la
tecnología no supere A lo mejor David no
van a poder hacer
submarinos con mayor capacidad o sea lo
que voy con todo eso es que
se democratiza no podemos decir que es
ocioso más bien es experimental y al
principio Es lógico que no da más las
élites lo hagan pero algo que fue tan
elitista como fue volar en los años hace
siete años ahorita una cosa que es súper
súper recurrente no en cuanto a los
riesgos por eso la misma gente Sigue
practicando tipo de deportes y por eso
hay un turismo No si si la gente no
buscara esos riesgos Pues hay otro tipo
de turismo más tranquilo no más al
turismo sol y playa el turismo pero
precisamente por eso que la gente está
buscando experiencias genuinas únicas
pido una chica que que fue a pasar año
nuevo en una aldea de caníbales entonces
este tipo de de de locaciones o de cosas
extremas pues la gente las Busca porque
son lugares volvemos a lo mismo el ser
humano siempre va a buscar llegar a
donde muy pocos ceros seres humanos
hayan llegado o a donde nadie haya
llegado no Esa es la parte de la de de
de la búsqueda de llegar tan lejos del
ser humano no y antes de tocar y
concluir con esta parte que usted habla
de la democratización a través de las
élites muy brevemente qué tan amplio es
este turismo negro del que usted habla
en el mundo
tiene que gustar O sea no todo mundo le
gusta que querer que se va a morir no O
sea pero yo que he hecho dos que tres
actividades ecoturísticas muchas veces
firmar Oye si con ocho rápidos con ocho
rapé cuando ocho el tema de buceo de
clases firmamos O sea si pasa algo la
empresa no es responsable porque son
temas y seguro los seguros de gastos
médicos que tenemos no los cubren si
hacemos una actividad de riesgo no
Entonces
ahora turismo negro más fuerte no por
ejemplo
como cosas que son más riesgosas pues tú
has dicho pequeño todavía no incluso hay
cosas que yo mismo diría esto porque
como que que debe morir de cáncer por
allá Es una cosa que no que no me
gustaría no Rubén su idea para concluir
usted considera que estos viajes que hoy
por hoy pertenecen a las élites ayudan a
democratizar lo que quizás luego se
pueda volver algo más comercial para
explorar los océanos
Sí mira pienso que aún estamos muy lejos
de eso
como decía hay muy hay mucha tecnología
y de alto costo detrás de todo esto y
la ciencia en estos momentos la ciencia
puede invertir con a través de la
colaboración internacional y y con
algunos recursos que los países pueden
destinar pero con un objetivo que tiene
que ver con la exploración el
conocimiento el avance de la ciencia
pero de ahí a transformado esto en algo
turístico pienso que tienen que pasar
muchos años como como decía colega de
México es esto puede que aquí a cien
años más podemos tener digamos
una tecnología de carácter masivo que
permite el acceso digamos al público al
público común digamos que de ingreso
medio o ingresos bajos que pueda ser
esta esta exploraciones pero por ahora
Esto está muy restringido está muy
restringido digamos una gran inversión
que hace que se hace o con fines
científicos exploratorios por parte de
los países y con algún Elite de mucho
dinero que pueda darse este gusto pero
con este riesgo tremendo que que ya
vemos lo que lo que significa lo que
puede implicar y Oscar muy brevemente su
conclusión
sinceramente creo que
es importante que se den estos procesos
de investigación que la gente sea
consciente de los riesgos que sea
consciente de que es importante explorar
alguien mencionaba en en redes sociales
que una cosa más allá de las muertes por
supuesto lamentable Es que esto puede
llegar a retrasar otros procesos
Entonces es importante que las empresas
en procesos de investigación procesos de
personas que como decíamos que esto
entre a que más personas intenten
regular intenten prohibir este tipo de
actividades
y lo cierto Es que desde la técnica si
se hace bien los riesgos se mitigan como
decía el profesor Rubén ellos bajaron a
siete mil metros en un sumergible de
14.000 Entonces en ese sentido si
tenemos claros los límites si podemos
hacer las cosas podemos explorar esos
lugares ir al espacio y está la luna
vista estar Marte crear una comunidad en
esos entornos pero sí es importante que
no subestimemos estos procesos que
entendamos Que hay riesgos siempre
inherentes y que sigamos adelante bueno
que sigamos adelante Entonces es un poco
el llamado de nuestros invitados Oscar
Iván Ojeda y ampute Franco y Rubén
escribano Gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en el debate y a ustedes gracias por
sintonizarnos la producción estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncel y la de los
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera sigan
con nosotros
[Música]